Now that we're familiar with placing actors and navigating Unreal Engine, let's talk
about working with materials and how we actually get some desired results from Unreal Engine.
So the topics we'll cover here are the real-time material concepts, we'll talk about what PBR
is and we'll also talk about parent materials and also material instances. So parent materials
being the primary PBR inputs, the node settings and exposing the different parameters and
then with material instances, it will talk about almost being a childhood version of
this parent material which is a more simplified interface and we can create multiple versions
of lighter, in this instance, more optimized materials based on that parent.
Real-time material concepts, essentially starting off as what is a material? It is essentially
an asset applied to a mesh to control its visual look. In its simplest form, think of
it as paint with various properties such as color and finish. So if we see on the right
hand side here, we'll see our paint brush and our bucket and tin, should we call it,
and we'll be able to paint a certain surface and let's say we decide that this surface is glass.
Now the eye looks at the glass and glass has reflective properties and it reflects a lot of
light as well. So you'll see the surface next to it bounces off that light and it creates some
reflection and inside of Unreal Engine, we define these properties of what we want glass to look
like. Whereas when we have chalk, if we set certain parameters on the material to say we want this to
be chalk, it disperses the light, it's much more of a matte material, there's not as much bounce
going off the light and especially in one direction. So there's a clear difference between how we want
glass to look and how we want chalk to look and we can define that all within Unreal Engine. So
material defines how the light interacts with the surface it is applied to essentially. And then
talking about PBR, PBR is a unified lighting and shading system. So it's a better approximation
of light and materials for physical interaction. So it's very intuitive and consistent, you get
specific results from using PBR, it's physically accurate and uses real-world physical measurements.
So PBR is a combination of you creating the materials, setting up the lighting how you
want it to be set up and also the exposure used within the scenes which is controlled
through the post-process. Looking at the material editor as an overview, you'll see a whole bunch
of nodes here connected into this master section here. So we can set up various parameters, maybe
we want to change the texture coordinates of a texture and we want to offset the texture maybe
and then maybe we want to add some contrast through a linear interpolate and we want to
set a base color for certain samples and maybe we want to add a normal map to it. Again these
materials can get super complex, we'll go over a basic material setup in a few slides here. But
you can see there's a lot going on under the hood when we can set up materials, a lot of
power and flexibility. You can also decide on certain material properties down on the
bottom left heel. So what type of material domain is it, is it a surface, what type of blend mode
do you want, do you want an opaque material, do you want a transparent material, what kind of
material do you want to set up and then also what shading model do you want it to use and there's
a lot more functionality as you scroll down the list in the material editor to get the desired
results of what you want there. When we're talking about PBR, the primary inputs you're talking about
are base color, metallic and roughness. So base color is some kind of flat color without
specularity, it's a linear RGB which is a vector 3 and the values are between 0 and 1. The metallic
input, so you'll see these base colors, you'll see metallic and you'll see roughness down here on the
right hand side but the metallic is a grayscale value that will range from 0 to 1 and more often
than not you really want the metallic value to be either 1 or 0. So when 1, its specular reflection
is at 100% so it's the most metallic version, 0 is the least metallic version. And then roughness,
grayscale value that ranges from 0 to 1 and you can actually transition through this area on 1
in the roughness so you could have you know 0.35 for example but it ranges from smooth, mirror-like
to a rougher more matted surface. So depending on the roughness of the material that you want
you can manipulate that property to have the desired result that you want.
We have a lot of different parameters available to us, we can right click anywhere in the material
editor and again I'll be creating a basic material in a few slides here but you can right click
anywhere in the material editor and create you know vector parameters, anything you need
as well as change the parameter values on each of the nodes that you create. So say you created
this vector 3 parameter here, you could select it and then set the colour, a lot of powerful
functionality which I'll be going through in a second and so and then you can create a material
instance that we spoke about at the start. So material instance is still a version of this
master material but it's got certain parameters exposed like brightness for example which we can
manipulate based on the parent properties but it's just a much more optimized unified way of
working. So let's go into Unreal, let's create a basic material, let's show you the different
options and then let's create a material instance for that as well.
you